ils étaient les meilleurs d'entre nous
aux meilleurs pilotes commencent à taper
l'intérieur
c'est l'élite
ce sont maintenant des légumes nos
meilleurs légumes non il y en a
maintenant bon alors préoccupe harlem
tronche je pourrais donne moi des
calculs cinq poussins
oh on est les moustaches youth on est là
pour faire peur
on a des nouvelles des deux bagagistes
non complètement notre affaire c'est
encore loin ce foutu que j'ai a priori
la dépasser les tiges à cinq mètres d'où
le mur
ce ministre ici oui alors on vient de
récupérer deux individus oui a lancé
n'ont pas boudé canam ne faut pas s'ils
sont dus à 402 bloqué au rez-de-chaussée
s'arrêter lui ou elle vous tablier ou
plutôt non je quelqu'un a compris
oui je moi ils ont moi disons quelqu'un
d'autre surtout aux bourgeoisies et dont
il connaît le prénom